[Music]
so you like yeah yeah you should think
about how quickly this that man made a
snake it's a big snake it's a scary
snake now it's just next naked it's gone
[Music]
[Music]
boy you trippin Dahlia
getting so good it's so good
[Applause]
[Music]
the amazing thing about will he brings
all his dimensions to it and you get to
see Jeannie with incredibly different
flavors you kind of just watch him and
you're just like this is how Ladin would
feel if he was watching the Jeannie
10,000 years I have never once ever
called a master friend I think a lot of
my job was encouraging will to be with
snake snake in the sky so you I'm not
who mom seems I'm in it who's just fun
on set whatever what will your pleasure
be dying gave me the freedom to create
with my hip-hop background to sort of
you know try to bring a little Big
Willie flavor to it
come whisper to me whatever it is you
want to build mated his own completely
insane vile and swagger to the genie you
know we grew up on Will Smith rapper big
really style a little big really the
style that comes in there a little fresh
pretty latitude it's really it really is
as a haka Singh rap dance it kickin me
get champ you should see these places I
mean there's a whole world outside of
books and maps do you want to
how every door is guarded we said
anything about a door what are you doing
sometimes princess sometimes you just
have to take a risk
what just happened is this a magic
carpet
do you trust me
what did you say do you trust me
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a whole new
we don't mind me
[Music]
[Music]
we're starting the first set up of whole
new world so we have to go up all set of
stairs and then up onto a rig there's a
LED screen set up on either side of us
so that we can kind of create an
ambiance you basically get hooked in
with these little ropes so that we don't
go flying and we're on a rig that's
about 15 feet up so if you're afraid of
heights you can't ride a magic carpet
[Music]
splendid tell me princess
did you last let your heart decide
hey girl how beautiful she looks
I complement her head she makes one that
is literally how our relationship works
I'm not actually mean I do love him
really there she is there she is
what day are we on a whole new world -
yeah we don't sound very confident we
did this yesterday that's a key response
a lot of giggles she had the giggles
today that tired
giggly stage you get that at least once
a day though because you like in the
middle of a whole new outlook I'll just
look at him in he's at least he's so
hard to work with this is ridiculous 3t
man we got work to do man
we got worse
friend like me it's a very complicated
sequence but we're cutting it live so
it's it's really exciting playing
digital this fantastic working with
wills been incredible this even though
he's CGI is here every day acting with
me so that we can deliver a cohesive
performance you know I just leaned over
Tom I whispered in his ear I said hey
man look
you messed his next one up we have
another dude in here to look just like
you in 10 minutes and then he got it
right it's like just the best because I
inspired that's what I do I just keep
the energy - inspiration encouragement
[Music]
amazing I mean seriously the best past
me I could ask for it we just finished
friends like me yeah
[Music]
some respect boy genuflect down on 1d
now try your best to stay calm brush up
your Friday salon then come and meet a
spectacular culture
long as ten regular men definitely
he's base together pink Lord a hundred
bad guys with sword
[Music]
title
Naboo this is a magic carpet these
really do exist
hello carpet
let's see what we can do about your
situation here
[Music]
don't mention it
guys but director who plays with
creative ways of shooting different
sequences like the camera moves and one
jump was a challenge because 24 frames
is what we normally shoot at which is
real time just in order to give it a
creative and new idea everything within
it is either fast or slow but he has to
remain in sync so it's all shot at 36
frames which means that slow motion
which means he has to sing very quickly
to keep up with the words so Punjab head
of the red line or whatever it is right
and vice versa so we did the other
server 18 frames which is the singing
like this one jump or bundle it up in
order to keep up with the work
[Music]
Guy Ritchie doing stunts in a Disney
film like come on he knew exactly what
he wanted he brought his years of
experience of creating stories about
Pheebs your plays bad a scene and not
well now that's your reason
so come on and try try to shut me and
cut me
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
they was clear to us as the script was
developing that this Jasmine was going
to be more powerful than ever someone
who would have this moment of really
standing up and saying I do have a voice
I will not remain speechless and knowing
that Naomi Scott was gonna take the song
and sing it gave us a lot of confidence
that we could write a song that is as
big and that is as powerful and that
says as much as it does because she's
the kind of actress and she has the kind
of voice that really can deliver that
God's speechless starts with a solo
piano
very intimate and you really get into
this soul of jasmine written in stone
every word as she gets taken away by the
gods this feeling has been bubbling up
you know cuz I and the amazing Alan
Menken was unset and helped me figure
out how the song fully kicks in was very
special that moment
[Music]
I'll never forget guy coming up with the
idea for the one-shot basically the idea
being that the Camerons spin around
jasmine so is going to be this whole
continuous thing so we did it in one
take the camera is just following her
[Music]
can you guess what it is oh good is it a
giraffe no nut is it a male cow oh
you're so close is it a female cows is
it a gaggle of geese no so it's not a
gaggle you naughty girls lied not good
at this game
surprise it's in Scotland everything we
make is sleek and minimal oh it's very
impressive but we are humble people
Prince Anders not impressed with the
gift so much is the sentiment behind it
sentiments it's for your desire for more
no it's a very big gun I could just make
you a prince Oh No right you'd be
snuggled up with that dude for the rest
of your life
okay I had a guy one time called if ie
the snake wish to be irresistible to all
women yeah that was good for about 90
seconds sticky feet Sharif wished that
anything I touched with tons of
[Music]
[Music]
moral of the story be clear be specific
with your words the deal is in the
detail when the shadows unfold when the
Sun hides its gold when the wind and the
cold come come when the path isn't clear
and the stars as men dismay at the edge
of the sky there's a moon hanging high
when you're lost it'll try to remind you
on a dog test night you come up to the
line because that charming third find
you
[Music]
the way
till the dog turns to day
I can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess
what would I have to do there's a Cave
of Wonders
bring me the man
[Music]
oh great one who summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty two wishes three I'm
kidding rush this
[Music]
you ain't never had a friend
hey can you make me a prince there is a
lot of gray area in make me a prince I
could just make you a prince oh no you
look like a prince on the outside but I
didn't change anything on the inside
Showtime
no I'm in charge okay I say when it's
done
[Music]
really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
[Music]